seven six too long a countdown
one no that's too short 15 14. too long
here we go
hey welcome to conan o'brien needs a
friend i started today's podcast uh
you're not going to hear this part but i
was doing a countdown yeah i was going
to counting myself down which i thought
was very professional and then i
realized i chose too high a number to
count down from i just randomly went to
15. yeah i think you should keep that in
yeah i'll leave that in so people know
what you're talking about it was just
all over the map and i thought and it
was my attempt to be professional
fifteen four nope that's no good how
about uh and then i went too early i
went to i think to one which don't go to
one three is the right way to start
don't you think three yeah two that's
the right way next time i do this i'm
just new to all of it i'm going to start
at three i will you're three years in
you're not new to this you're not new
anymore you keep acting like oh podcasts
what's that it's like you've been doing
it for three years well you know i have
short-term memory uh loss i have severe
i just keep
wow
a podcast unless someone messes up then
it's something you bring up like seven
years later
i have an amazing
memory
for someone else's failure
i can remember if someone else slightly
screwed up yep 57 years ago
i can smell that moment taste that
moment feel that moment i can describe
everything in the room that's what i'm
good at right sona yes yes yes you bring
up things i forgot to do like 12 years
ago it's small things too it's like oh
remember i emailed you and you didn't
respond to me to let me know you got the
email right remember the time that i
needed that medication to stay alive and
you didn't get it for me you were out
here
you were out at a rave and you drank you
drank the blue stuff that was in the
glow stick and you and your friends
threw up on top of each other and both
got radioactive yep i remember that
that's a true story uh it's not okay
well as you can tell i'm joined by
my crack team
um you guys are a crack team you really
are yeah you're just so on top of it all
the time i'm gonna disagree i think matt
is i'm not so half of your team is a
craft team matt i think you are you know
what i'm gonna give you a compliment
matt and hang on to this because you're
never getting another one of these again
you actually do stuff you actually
you actually uh
you produce this podcast you do a lovely
job you go through it you make sure that
you know uh it all lines up and it's
technically proficient uh that's a
little i know about what you do is that
i just said it all lines up um
sona and i are just uh chimps that have
been put into a space capsule that just
hit each other and throw pancake batter
at each other and then uh you know
you're in mission control making making
us uh you know get up in the atmosphere
and back safely that's what you do yeah
i think that's fair yeah so god bless
you matt gurley thanks are you putting
us on the same level you do all the
interviews i really don't do much i mean
this is a big scam that i know i've got
yeah
oh i know i know what i did was i i
tricked sona into complimenting me so
she just said conan you're the one that
does all the interviews
and then uh you were left out in the
cold sona so that was a beautiful thing
that i just did as soon as the heart i'm
the brains you're the obstacle we have
to get over that's true to make this go
that's true
i'm the uh yeah that's right you're a
hindrance
yeah uh yeah that's right you're i'm
gonna put it this way uh sona
is uh the christmas spirit um and matt
is bruce willis and uh i am hans gruber
oh i like this yeah yeah yeah yippee
[ __ ] yeah tell me about these
cowboys you know whatever i don't wow is
that your german accent i know i'll work
on it i i didn't give it any thought and
i think i also at the same time
something burst in my brain so i can't
be he didn't even have a german accent
though didn't he alan rickman was just
speaking in his british accent wasn't he
no he was not friends
he had had a bit of a german accent it
was sort of one of those it's like he
came from the bad guy
region
of
central eastern
europe do you know what i mean it's just
60s nazi yeah it was one of those very
vague there's like a country that's near
uh lithuania
um but it also borders belgium and
that's where all bad guys are from
welcome mr bond so nice to have you i i
do hope you're comfortable mr bond and
they all come from that one little
country all of them